boa noite meus caros
essa não é mais uma palestra
motivacional é simplesmente uma quebra
das algemas da mesmice inclusive as
minhas mostro para vocês a história do
homem médio
o homem médio não é assim chamado porque
tem mediana estatura mediana no peso e
medianidade o homem médio é aquele
previsível padrão
o homem médio acorda às 7 horas da manhã
o irritante alarme de galo cantando
sonhando ser uma doce música de
propaganda de margarina
ele acorda e vai dizer johar a sua
linhaça dourada com o orkut de aveia
estando radiante porque fez um belo
trabalho no banheiro pela manhã
não porque ele se importa com as
pequenas coisas da vida porque ele gosta
de seguir as tendências porque ele
aprendeu no programa de sexta feira à
noite que era uma receita infalível um
homem médio vai por seu escritório de
advocacia o di'anno tudo ea todos
principalmente aquela pilha de processos
atrasados mas o salário no fim do mês
compensa toda a chatice suas relações
pessoais são educadas porém extremamente
superficiais
afinal não quer parecer arrogante e
sendo assim pra ele basta contribuir com
a caixinha de natal da portaria e da
esmola no final o homem médio já no
almoço opto por uma segunda feira sem
carne
não porque está convicto que o
vegetarianismo é uma opção ética e
alimentar importante não porque está
preocupado com o impacto ambiental disso
tudo simplesmente porque ele acha muito
bacana seguir a tendência da atriz de
novela já até baixou uma receita de suco
box venha alguma falha belas na rede
social que a felicidade está em como
achar o par perfeito principalmente se
você está beirando os 30 de preferência
ela recatada e doar ou se preferir belo
revelado lá tanto faz
e no fim de semana ir para qualquer
lugar
visualmente legal não parece contemplar
mas sim pra muitos likes no aplicativo
de fotos
esse é o homem médio se pudéssemos
quantificar um homem médio teríamos uma
unidade de medida de comportamento
humano
nada mais que uma mera constante entre
tantas possibilidades estatísticas
esse homem médio social o direito também
apresenta ser uma equipa organizada
longe de ser apenas um conceito dito em
sala de aula
um homem médio é aquele que se fácil
presumir nada mais que uma ficção é cada
vez mais onipresentes inspiram ações
públicas e leis
ele tem com o comportamento constante
cujas diligências sensibilidade e os
sentimentos éticos e morais sejam
representativos de uma população em
geral
posso citar dois exemplos nada usuais
que percebam a presença do homem médio
social social influenciado no direito
deles
quando o homem médium se casa
normalmente com quantos anos
beirando os 30 anos 30 e se casa
pensemos por amor vencemos o
companheirismo pensemos se eu quiser me
casar aos 70 o que o homem médio pensa
disso nossa 70 isso tá parecendo um
golpe do baú o direito então restringe a
vida da pessoa que quer casar 70 e
presume que por amor não é presume que
não é
seja aquele que quer se casar aos 70
pode se casar mas desde que com o regime
de bens restrito não passando os bens
para o outro casal
assim o segundo exemplo que eu posso
trazer que o homem social o homem médio
social restringe o homem médio do
direito aconteceu com o famoso diretor
de teatro há pouco tempo atrás após a
peça encerrar uma grande vaia tomou
conta da platéia ele como resposta
simplesmente girou de costas abaixou as
calças e as nádegas foram à mostra
aquele homem médio que criticando a peça
teatral vaiou o denunciou por ato
obsceno
o denunciou por ato obsceno mas o stf
foi muito pontual na sua decisão
ele falou não isso é meramente direito
de liberdade de expressão aqueles que
estavam na platéia eram maiores de idade
no decorrer da madrugada e tinha acabado
de ver cenas que atrás de sexo explícito
se você se sentiu ofendido com aparente
indecência
desculpe você é um homem médio
me desculpe politicamente correto nós
vamos falar um pouco sobre essa tal
liberdade a liberdade constitui o
direito do ser humano sendo direito mais
particular e próprio dele assim
liberdade é compreendida como autonomia
aptidão de dirigir sua vida aptidão de
dirigir sua vida com base numa lógica um
motivo o direito então de marca um
espaço
dentre os quais diversas ações são
lícitas ou seja legítimas permitidas
para melhor explicar eu falo de
amplitude de liberdade amplitude de
escolhas
você pode fazer tudo que a lei não
proíbe e até nas proibidas
pode-se agir arcando com a punição ética
e estatal
posso matar alguém desde que eu seja
poluído duramente por isso e saiba disso
a idéia não é só fazer o que é permitido
mas sim tudo que não é proibido ea nossa
constituição tais claramente isso artigo
5º inciso 2º ninguém será obrigado a
fazer ou deixar de fazer alguma coisa
senão em virtude de lei
como diria música de raul seixas ao
citar a doutrina islâmica
faça tudo o que tu queres pois é tudo da
lei amplitude de liberdade amplitude nas
escolhas
se eu puder usar uma metáfora
pensemos uns você é isso
na época de criança querendo e pela
necessidade de ir para a escola sozinha
sou livre
quem quer que essa opção foi menos
padrão possível quero ir à escola
andando de skate
seus pais desesperados seus ralados no
cotovelo dizem muito o desespero dele
não filho vai de carona não filho de
bicicleta com rodinhas talvez não filho
eu te levo o melhor mais mediano de tudo
e de todos desculpe eu pago uma van para
você ir mais um ele quis sair do padrão
ele 15 andando de skate
essa metáfora pra amplitude de escolhas
então vou propor a liberdade de se
pensar a liberdade de ser protagonista
ser livre pode significar sua vida não
amarrada pelo estado mas hoje está
encorajada pela sociedade por aquele que
está do seu lado seguir idéias é muito
mais cômodo que temas a sociedade deve
responder ao direito eo direito à
sociedade
enquanto o direito abre possibilidades a
sociedade pune aqueles que fogem dela
sanfona com olhares recrimina com redes
sociais
vira boato na boca ganha mas porque
simplesmente seguir cegamente opiniões
se o direito de permitir liberdades como
a de consciência crença e pensamento o
que vem a ser isso
essas liberdades eu posso entender como
uma ampla noção ligada à faculdade de um
indivíduo formular juízos idéias e
opiniões seja sobre si mesmo seja sobre
o mundo que o cerca
representa portanto uma determinação uma
determinação jurídica para que o estado
e as pessoas no seu lado não interfiram
no seu próprio ser
eu chamo essas liberdades de ser
protagonista de ser protagonista o
direito de dar ampla possibilidade de
fazer a tudo o que aqui não está
permitido mas o padrão social segue uma
regra ser protagonista é passear está a
princípio fora desse padrão social
passear por toda amplitude de liberdade
que o direito te dá os que sabem usar
essa liberdade
eu chamo de protagonistas não uma
história de sucesso financeiro ou de
fama
sim aquele que utiliza amplitude
permitida de escolhas e foge de um
padrão social protagonista então é o
principal puxador como forma de provar o
que eu digo que sinto trechos da
constituição da república a declaração
universal dos direitos humanos artigo 5º
incisos quarto e sexto
todos são iguais perante a lei é livre a
manifestação de pensamento sendo vedado
o anonimato é inviolável a liberdade de
consciência no trecho da declaração
universal dos direitos humanos
toda pessoa tem direito à liberdade de
pensamento
consciência e de religião este direito
implica a liberdade de mudar de religião
assim como a liberdade de manifestar a
religião ou convicção sozinho ou em
comum tanto em público como privado
todo indivíduo tem direito à liberdade
de opinião e de expressão o que implica
o direito de não serem afetados pelas
suas opiniões e de procurar receber e
difundir elas nos carros
o direito não serve para limitar suas
ações mas sim para legitimar a amplitude
das mesmas
se você é livre para pensar deve ter o
aval pra agir não se deve esperar uma
conduta de alguém mas sim uma opv tude
de condutas corretas
a ideia é que você pode ser mais o
direito de permitir fugir do padrão do
homem médio
a busca pela consciência de ser não
quero que ninguém seja punido por ser
protagonista nem tão pouco os homens
médios se fizerem uma escolha de vida
condenar é diferente de instigar a
mudança a figura do homem médio padrão
ideal de conduta é uma construção a
coisa se ficar 11 uma tradução de
convenções como verdades
a série reproduzidas e não questionados
fora da realidade de forma alheia
alienada abstrata é o próprio
engessamento da sociedade e muitos de
nós hoje nos damos tenha consciência
pense seja livre até para escolher ser
um homem médio
faço das palavras de um libertário
americano
as minhas nós não somos o que
gostaríamos de ser
nós não somos o que ainda iremos ser mas
graças a deus não somos mais quem nós
éramos martin luta em que você
escolher a continuar adiante com um belo
trabalho feito no banheiro e ter
relações frágeis
vou fazer igual o menino e aprender a
andar de skate
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]